hello there
welcome back everyone to stream in the
galaxy my name is rocket riley and today
we're going to be going over everything
we know so far about the obi-wan kenobi
series coming soon to disney plus but
before we get started if you're new to
the channel please hit the subscribe
button and click the bell icon to be
notified when we upload a new video the
obi-wan kenobi series will be set 10
years after the events of revenge of the
sith where he faced his greatest defeat
the downfall and corruption of his best
friend and jedi apprentice anakin
skywalker otherwise known as the evil
sith lord darth vader the show will
follow obi-wan as he watches over the
young luke skywalker on tatooine facing
unknown threats and overcoming many
obstacles along the way which will
likely take him off planet the show is
set to release sometime in 2022 on
disney plus and it'll feature a total of
six episodes the series began production
in april of 2021 and finished filming by
september of 2021 according to an
interview with ewan mcgregor while the
specifics of the obi-wan kenobi story
remain unclear several canonical star
wars stories do reveal some of the
veteran jedi's activities during his
post revenge of the sith exile on
tatooine in the comics titled from the
journals of obi-wan kenobi luke
skywalker discovers his old masters
diaries which detail what obi-wan was up
to during this time we know he was
frustrated at having to keep his jedi
status a secret and his inability to
train the young luke in the ways of the
force
at one point uncle owen even demanded
that kenobi keep his distance from the
family and their moisture farm however
obi-wan still did his best to protect
the family including saving owen from a
run-in with black chrysanthen a wookie
bounty hunter we also recently received
a first look at the series on disney
plus which featured some amazing concept
art in the first piece we see obi-wan
writing a neop on tatooine looking older
and more rugged closer to how alec
guinness appeared in a new hope ewan
mcgregor will reprise his role as
obi-wan kenobi on screen for the first
time since 2005's revenge of the sith
although he had a couple of brief voice
cameos in the force awakens and the rise
of skywalker the second piece of concept
art features an inquisitor ship along
with an inquisitor and two stormtroopers
while it had been rumored that some
inquisitors may show up on tatooine in
search of jedi such as obi-wan and
potential jedi like luke it's now
basically confirmed with this concept
art we've seen these jedi hunting
inquisitors before in some of the star
wars animated series as well as in the
video game jedi fallen order
there have also been rumors that
characters such as darth maul will make
an appearance in the show and
considering maul's long history with
kenobi this seems pretty likely
a february 2021 instagram post from ray
park the actor who plays darth maul may
also hint at his return
the third piece of concept art shows us
what looks like an underwater or
otherwise off tatooine empire base with
stormtroopers standing in small groups
this further points to the idea that the
show may take us off tatooine if
off-world threats arise which obi-wan
must face
the fourth piece of concept art features
darth vader sitting in a throne room
perhaps in his fortress on mustafar as
confirmed at disney's investor day in
december of 2020 actor hayden
christensen will be joining the cast as
darth vader in the concept art vader
sits in front of a hologram potentially
speaking with emperor palpatine so
there's a chance we could see another
appearance from ian mcdermott the last
and maybe the most exciting piece of
concept art shows a fiery rematch
between obi-wan and his apprentice
anakin
when obi-wan left anakin munilated and
burning on the volcanic surface of
mustafar he must have assumed anakin had
died so we're guessing the fact that
he's alive as darth vader is going to
come as quite a big shock to obi-wan and
this revelation could be a contributing
factor to how kenobi is willing to leave
tatooine since we know there's almost no
way kenobi would risk the empire or the
sith coming near luke on the other hand
if vader realizes that kenobi is alive
it's likely that he would be obsessed
with tracking him down and eliminating
him we already know that after the
destruction of the first death star
darth vader traveled to jabba's palace
to recruit a bounty hunter boba fett to
track down a certain force sensitive
pilot so vader making his way to
tatooine in the show is not out of the
question vader and kenobi's eagerly
anticipated rematch doesn't have to
retcon or go against previously
established canon either while we'd
assumed their battle on mustafar was the
last time they had saw each other before
a new hope the timeline is somewhat
vague
in a new hope vader describes kenobi as
a presence i've not felt since and that
sense could be this encounter we see in
the concept art
either way it'll be so exciting to see
vader go toe to toe with his old master
once again
in april of 2021 the full cast for the
show was revealed joel edgerton and
bonnie pierce are confirmed to be
returning as uncle owen and aunt baru
lars the couple who raised luke
skywalker after obi-wan left the child
on tatooine
other confirmed cast members include
camille nanjani from the big sick and
the eternals
indira varma from game of thrones rupert
friend from homeland o'shea jackson jr
from straight out of compton
sung kang from the fast and the furious
series simone kessel from the crossing
benny safty from good time and maya
erskine from penn 15.
rumors say that erskine will be in at
least three episodes so erskine's
character may have a prominent role in
the story
the biggest name who may be returning
though is luke skywalker at this point
in the timeline luke would be around 10
years old so we may get to see a young
luke skywalker before the events of a
new hope
after all luke already knows old ben at
the start of a new hope and the whole
reason kenobi stayed on tatooine was to
keep an eye on luke when ewan mcgregor
was asked if he was doing screen tests
with potential actors for young luke he
said that's very possible i don't know
and we all know mcgregor is good at
keeping secrets as he held in the secret
about the kenobi series for years so
there may be some truth to the rumors
surrounding luke's return
other characters who are rumored to
return are qui gon jin and master yoda
at the end of revenge of the sith yoda
says to obi-wan an old friend has
learned the path to immortality one who
has returned from the netherworld of the
force your old master meaning that
qui-gon had learned how to become a
force ghost so while we may not see
qui-gon in the flesh it's likely that
he'll return in a spiritual form
we may also see yoda teaching obi-wan
how to master this ability as we know
both yoda and obi-wan have mastered it
by the later star wars films the series
is also confirmed to be using the same
volume technology that was used for the
filming of the mandalorian the volume is
a completely domed virtual set with
screens that actually put actors and
actresses in the stories environment
rather than using blue screens and green
screens the results of this look
absolutely stunning in the mandalorian
so we can probably expect a similar
product in the obi-wan kenobi series
lastly we know who the writers and
directors are for the series deborah
chao who directed two episodes of the
mandalorian will be the head director of
the show and army of the dead writer
joby herald is the head writer for the
six part series
lucasfilm president kathleen kennedy
michelle rejuan chao mcgregor and harold
will serve as executive producers
overall this show looks like it'll have
an exciting story taking us on thrilling
adventures with the fan favorite
character obi-wan once again i can't
wait to see what the series brings us
and i hope it brings some clarity to the
events that happened between episodes 3
and 4. ewan mcgregor recently said in an
interview to come back and to play him
again obi-wan kenobi has been absolutely
brilliant i'm really enjoying it and i'm
sure the fans will absolutely enjoy it
too only a sith deals in absolutes
well that's gonna be everything we know
about the obi-wan kenobi series so far
if you enjoyed the video please hit the
like button and don't forget to
subscribe for more great content what
are your theories for the show will we
actually get to see a young luke on
screen we'd like to know what you think
so drop your thoughts in the comment
section below
from everyone here at stream in the
galaxy we hope you have a great day and
thanks for watching